we're fighting
just for our land
and for our freedom
despite the fact
that all like cities of our country are
now blocked
nobody
is going to
enter and intervene with our freedom and
country and believe you me every square
of today no matter what it's called it's
going to be called
as today freedom square
in every city of our country
nobody's going to break us
we're strong
we're ukrainians
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
infrastructure
is
foreign
foreign
[Music]
i'd like to inform that now it's bombing
yes the memorial yes the memorial which
that we made
they started building after
uh 80 years of this tragedy
foreign
terrorists
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
is
[Music]
foreign
m
is
[Music]
in order to show my support for ukraine
i recently sat down with two people who
are in ukraine giving their stories from
the streets i hope you enjoy
how we doing very much
hey glad to hear your
everything
is calm
and we are healthy and safe so
yeah thanks for the call thanks it's
pleasure to see you first time my first
words i want to say thank you to
canada to all your people in canada to
all your government to justin trudeau
thank you for all your support for all
these warm words for all your prayers so
yeah we hear you and it really support
us because we understand that we are not
alone
and my second
words i want to say
thank you for our brave soldiers they
shown
really unique courageous
they're really brave
and thank you to
our president
because
he is
really brave and i don't know i can't
see his eyes without
tears on my eyes you know i see how this
young person how he's tired and i see
how
difficult
to communicate with russia and all
this terrible
situations that's happening it's
it's really it's really hard to
feel it you know so yeah it's my it's my
first words
i love it now now first off i guess you
and your family are are safe
right now
yeah man you know
we i think that we won
a golden ticket from willy wonka
because
we was in mountains
in the west of country it's a
about
15 kilometers from the border with
europa in union and
we walked there
first day we arrived we celebrate
my dear friends birthday
and
the next day we wake up because the work
has been started
and uh
yeah it's really far from kiev from from
russian border what is life
like for you now i mean is there any is
there any kind of normalcy what i mean
what is what does day-to-day life look
like for you right now you know honestly
i can say about my daily life because
on each regions on each part of country
there are different lights for because
all the people you know i have friends
that uh sitting now in the bunkers in
kiev i had
friends that tried to
go out from hakeef from mario paul
and they're really difficult a different
uh different light there so
my life now it's uh
we started
fund raising campaign
and the people around the world
from united states from montenegro even
from ukraine they
paid
they paid funds and we
buying
a food
food is for now it's really important to
buy food
to people
in the east of country we buy a lot of
potatoes
carrots onions
spaghetti
and rice so
you know it's so strange that in
21st century the people needs all the
stuff in the center of europe
it's a it's a crazy man i saw on your
instagram stories you're posting and
it's like pictures of your trunk
uh i can't understand the words but
there's there's the potatoes and the in
the trunk and the onions and all the
food
um and you know it's great what you're
doing man i'm trying to try to spread
the
spread the love but also spread you know
the resources that people need
um somebody's asking in the chat too
where where can they donate if somebody
wanted to join you don't know what's
what's the best process
so
now we are considering different ways to
start the
fundraising campaign we're all thinking
about the website but
i
will create a post and i really
appreciate you if you can
share it also the people
can watch my instagram and see
what will happen with theirs money
i dreaming
to find now some solutions to work with
volunteers from the
slovakia and to
find some equipment for our soldier
uh
because they're really nice because
there are a lot of mobilization now in
ukraine and a lot of people go into the
army
and we want to support our government
with that
so for people who are watching who are
you know not in ukraine but are watching
the news and hearing your story and
want to help
uh what what are the options what do you
what do you want to tell them how can
people support i mean when we get the
link we can share that
but what else can we do
sure
the world's
i think that
the first important thing that i think
that all the world
have to be connected we have to
collaborate with each other you people
around the world they they have to
create some posts to
show what's happening there now in
ukraine also we
dreaming
to
for the nato support to
clean our sky
it's really important
clean our sky from
missiles from
aircrafts
because the each day even our can say
that each
minus and each seconds this
russian forces aviation forces they
bombing our cities and
dying there not soldiers
dying there
breed little babies dying their old
peoples
and
it's a i don't know i know say it's
terrible
how far does
a hundred dollars go like if somebody's
watching and and puts a hundred a
hundred dollars us in what does that
actually let you do
okay
uh you see
you saw today my car result of potatoes
a result of carrots so we spent about
the
uh
sixty dollars for it
uh for forty dollars we bought some food
like rices uh
some peppers or something like that so
to
buy
uh about 30 40 kilograms of food we need
about
16
so if you will have 100 we can increase
this
amount in two times the food is going
like what do you take you fill up your
car with potatoes and then use it yeah
yeah and where do you drive it who are
you taking it to
now in germany i think in all the big
cities and all in small cities in the
centers there are a huge
volunteer centers
that
create a huge communication with
different people with a
big cars
with trucks
and
all volunteers like me they bring a lot
of stuff in these centers
and they
separate it for to each city to each
small city to village and they
communicate with
drivers with drivers with big companies
that have to they had trucks or big cars
and they deliver it to the volunteer
centers in this city that now in attack
so the volunteer
centers it's about communication and
it's about delivery so
my main partner to find
all equipment to find
food to find all stuff that these
centers need sometimes is
they tapping like hey guys in a five
hours we had a truck that will move to
kiev so what we need
so
sometimes they need only just uh stuff
for the babies you got people from
around the world here who
are are
you know in
in uh in tears and just sending you lots
of love but what what final message
would you give them
uh people around the world who are
watching this
live or replay
uh
well
my final message is please support us as
how you can on your front
as you can be see your social media
the next my message is the
we are strong
glory of ukraine there she is
how you doing not bad uh shutting didn't
started yet so
and i i've heard some sound in the sky
and we went to the basement
and uh now i'm here hi everyone
are you and your family safe secure
at least for now everybody
yeah for the moment yes my uh family on
the left bank and i'm on the right one
so we are in the basement of our house
we are lucky to have it because it's
quite comfy we even have a hot water
here and the kind of kitchen
and my family stayed at their apartment
and in their middle room because there
is
two walls rule now
because you have to hide from the
shelling and to to have two walls
between you and the
street so
yeah we're kind of hiding and waiting
for it alone
so we've got people kind of watching in
and tuning in from around the world and
we'll continue to watch in the replay
what do you want them to know i mean we
see things on the news but you're there
on the ground what what would be your
message to them
don't believe russians anymore never
nothing they're talking about their
spiritual cultural ballet literature
dostoyevsk
it's all covers aggression and i know
how to ex
explain what our feelings are because
the whole
people the whole nation that pretend to
be and call called brothers and
close ones uh they such a betrayal of
everything that that's we know who
russian is in ukraine because we
remember colonel moore when they took
all the bread and food from ukraine in
32
twice
we remember all the repressions and the
war
and before when they uh
didn't let us speak a ukrainian uh when
the catharina
the queen was so this is the 21st
conflict between our country this is not
first one and people don't know but this
is the 21st
from the very very early ages where
where their nights and our nights were
conflicted but now this is a very very
point
like we say this is the divorce with the
maniac
because russia is abusing abuser country
terroristic country
and ukraine in lots of people still
believe that they are human too you know
and now when they started to talk about
uh invading all ukraine
and uh telling that we are failing state
not them
uh
lying about we kind of have a
civil war here we don't never did
and now this is a very very point the
end of any good relations between
all the levels
even relative sometimes people don't
talk to their russian
relatives now so this is a divorce with
the maniac
what does uh
day-to-day life
look like for you right now with
everything going on
well um
three weeks ago i had a gig
with my rock band
and uh
i just had this strange feeling that it
could be lost but i thought it just you
know i'm the drama queen
i just no it can be true i'm too
sentimental yeah we have this tough
situation and don't don't buzz but i
think
nobody wants war after covet you know
the world is tired who can let
russia start the
third world war
but it happened
and now my daily life it's like from
alarm to alarm because
we're going up taking a shower making
breakfast i have a kid three years old
and we're waking her up and make some
food and
changing clothing and now we have a
short work in our yard and go go back
very fast and uh
we are trying to pretend that life is
normal you know like a plane lying to
kids that it just rockets it's like a
bad weather rocket weather
uh we will have a picnic in the basement
it will be fun
and uh it's from atlanta alarm and from
sms
messages to
uh from our friend that we are live cool
how are you we're alive where are you
we're leaving we're staying do you have
some food uh do you can you be online in
one hour and
now it's you know in
it's it
like uh
discreted
in small parts from good news to bad
news and vice versa
how often are the alarms going off
today it was twice but it was
three times one in the morning and twice
at night
and
i'm in the basement now
and uh
there are my shoulder sleeve actually
this is a wall gaming club
with the uh
people who like this table games and
they let us in
and um
uh
now we are like make shifts
today it was nine of us a family with
two kids us three and two more families
with two people
and uh
today we were promised
that some infrastructure objects not far
from us
could be bombing
and we saw some
in messages and telegram and
other
groups that it was a real warning and we
are like
very stressed out because we're waiting
for this and now it's getting dark and
we we have heard this uh
i don't know it's uh
some fly jets
they started to fly and we decided not
to wait for alarm and went down still
just waiting
and you're right in the capitol
yeah i'm in keith i'm in the center of
kiev i'm
what are you telling
your young child about what's going on
and
why why we're going up and down to
shelters and back to the apartment
uh westerland we don't pronounce
like putin a world war
but he uses a special operation against
some nazis
and what is lie because we know where
nazis are for the moment and we're just
lying to her i'm saying that it will be
fun we will make some new friends and uh
we're taking some fruit and toys and
books and i bought her uh this as
chocolate axe with small toys
and now she's jumping on the inflatable
mattress
because it's fun
and we just don't tell her what war is i
don't want and while she doesn't
hear the sound of bombing
uh because it's not not near us
i think uh
if her
uh
psycho party is still uh
okay
but i know that people in bucha in
europe
in gustoma that were bombed a lot
their
their kids have huge problems because
they are alert you know
all the time say afraid of uh
any sound
and
we're just making some new rules that
imagine that it was a little cat
that
went for a bombing weather it was a big
bad weather there would add some soon
some stories like this but don't go
close to the windows it's the rule
number one
or lie down on the floor very quickly
let's make a training let's rule number
two
so i'm just making these fairy tales not
too traumatized
but it's you know it's so
it's it's so bad that it is a part of
her childhood i wouldn't i wouldn't even
start it's it can happen to us
i mean you're doing a great job i can
only imagine
what what that would be like um you know
i have a i have a 12 year old son and
just couldn't imagine what that would
look like um let alone a you know
three-year-old daughter
um for people who are watching it means
people i'm in canada people are in the
us and around the world
how can we support
what you're doing
please support our army
because
we and our volunteers because we we have
these all swift codes for national army
support and the charity foundation and
for kids who don't have parents
that escape in ukraine please give me
give them shelter because we adults can
help ourselves
and they cannot
and you know
if you see ukrainian child please help
them
because if you can put i don't know i'm
a musician and and you if you could just
pray the truth
by putting our music online or on air i
don't know just reading our books or
telling the truth that
a lot of ukrainian russian great artists
these are ukrainian people
who were you know from soviet union
just tell them the truth about our
history and our culture and know about
us more because before it was like
ukraine worry this
other than the part of russia no we're
not
and now we just want to
separate ourselves from them as far as
possible
if you mention your musician where can
people find your music if they want to
support you
oh thank you so much if you want to we
are
available on any streaming platform
my band name is krihitka it's tiny
in uh
in english it's uh on my
facebook and my instagram
you can find it so thank you if you
if you will listen to this
we have really great musicians in
ukraine and if you find any spotify or
apple music uh playlist from ukraine you
will i hope you will like it thank you
so much well i'm gonna go take a listen
after so i'm excited for that um
for
so yesterday we had stass on my nose in
your your band as well and he was buying
food and potatoes and carrots and onions
for people
and people are asking how they can
donate to help
are there
specific charities that you recommend
we've talked about airbnb waiving their
fees so it goes right to ukrainians like
if somebody wants to support
where would you recommend them putting
some money
i would recommend to support
their
the hospital ahmad dead from kiev where
people were children with cancer and
aids get treatment and some
very hard conditions because there are
people in the basement now with very
small kids and this is just so full you
know i have a healthy kid and it's awful
i just
can't realize what do they fail if you
can't support people from ahmad
it's uh
our central children's hospital it would
be just great and so
grateful for this
okay i love it we'll try to get that
information i'll put it in the in the
link afterwards um
you know i know i know uh it's a
stressful time for you and we may not
have a ton of time um
you know final message for people
watching
what do you want to tell them
support us in our
we're struggling for freedom it's not
it's not about ukraine you know
because what russia's thoughts
it's not about ukraine only poland can
be next anybody can be next because they
are just terroristic state for the
moment
they are support they are supported by
the nation who was lied for 20 years
they are blind
you know they're locked
they are uh now have no free internet
you know they are going to make their
own web
and spread their lie
don't let russian television invade your
channels your you know ban them ban them
because theirs first goes lie second
goes by of violence
and putin is just some crazy old soviet
cagivist maniac
who is so
self-obsessed that could start a
nuclear war
this is now reality we have to stop him
ukrainians do their best to stop him but
you know the world would like to unite i
i realize that nato cannot
close the sky now because they're afraid
to be the part of the war and it would
make things harder but please give us
little weapon we want to stop them
invading europe invading the world
because they're just insane they are
from the very very past they don't see a
future like
people from western countries do like
possibilities they see a future like a
threat
because they are old so we have to stop
the invasion of these soviet zombies
sasha thank you for having the courage
to come on i know you've got a lot of
things on your mind right now and i
appreciate you spending some extra time
with us
so much love to you your family your
daughter i've you know prayed for a lot
of safety and we'll continue to we can
to support i'm abroad appreciate you so
much
thank you so much
canadian
i love i love the french your french's
your french is probably better than mine
i love it thank you sasha take care
we'll see you soon
if you want to support sas and sasha and
the causes they talked about we've
linked it up in the description below
for you to go check out also sasha is
the lead singer of a ukrainian rock band
we're going to show her video right now
so that her band can monetize any income
made from this video and you can support
her too
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
me
is
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
me
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
we need
[Music]
if you want to continue to support sasha
her band and the work she's doing go
check out her channel right there next
to me i think you'll love it continue to
believe and i'll see you there
[Music]